if democrats want to know what they're
going to be facing let's talk about it
right now because if i were a republican
running
i would say democrats can't protect us
across the world
democrats can't protect our street
and democrats can't protect us at the
border
that's how bad the democrats are doing
joe scarborough is a republican again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
super duper wednesday everyone yeah
all right
former president trump just released an
ad and it's really soft on president
biden
america is back the highest inflation
rate in the united states
threat environment the likelihood
there's going to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely
did i say soft
sorry about that that was as soft as
chris cuomo's skull
meaning not soft at all
that that's a chris cuomo's watching
you know i should really watch these
videos before i do the show instead of
doing shots of hand sanitizer with cat
[Laughter]
and america please don't say i told you
to drink hand sanitizer say cat dude
so let's have another taste shall we
they own the whole country now the
taliban taliban are now in complete
control of afghanistan
how did president biden get this so
wrong well first of all the mission
hasn't failed
yet i don't care if you think i'm satan
reincarnated
[Music]
hold on everybody we have to ask the
taliban for permission for american
citizens to leave true or not true they
they are in control i can't uh think of
anyone better to lead this operation
than
uh
they're just chanting death to america
call yourself a president
well
much like the wahlberg parents i fear
that will leave a mark
[Music]
that is a really terrible joke
and i'm so proud of it
but that video says what everyone
outside the media thinks that joe's a
human tea bag and he's always in hot
water we saw yesterday's horrible speech
it had the intimidating power of a
refrigerator magnet it was as
inspirational as the list of side
effects in a drug commercial as
energizing as eating a pound of pasta
after a stack of pancakes and chasing
that with a fistful of xanax he answered
fewer questions than the taliban and
split faster than stelter's pants on
donut day
and while all mines were on afghanistan
what did biden lead with the
progressives greatest hits all aimed at
us and not them
that today's vote in the house allowed
them to consider my build back better
agenda
a broad framework to make housing more
affordable provide two years of free
universal high quality pre-k
and two years of free community college
and making infrastructure more resilient
to climate to the climate crisis and so
much more look i also want to thank
everyone who voted to support the john
lewis voting rights act you know
advancing
it's an act to restore and expand voting
protections to prevent voter suppression
and to secure the most sacred of
american rights
the right to vote freely
the right to vote fairly and the right
to have your vote counted
so first you got free stuff which at
least didn't go to the taliban
still it's sort of like when your wife
gives you a crappy christmas gift bought
with your money sorry
our money
except here it leads to inflation and
unemployment
yeah thank god she's not watching we got
voter suppression without any evidence
that it exists we got climate change
which must be good news for the taliban
because according to newsweek the
taliban is now vowing to fight global
warming which you know i don't doubt
everybody agrees one cause of climate
change is
and you can argue no one has done more
to bring the number of people on this
planet down than the taliban at the rate
they kill people carbon emissions won't
be a problem in a couple of months
but that's the thing with joe's pressers
does he ever have a real answer or does
he just play with his wheel of excuses
okay this is how we get ready for a
press conference here we go
you're gonna have to ask jen saki yeah
she's good she's good
look
i inherited this thing all right
not enough people are wearing their
masks
what
that was like four or five days ago
come on man ask that again but just
change the words
just
walk away
what does that mean oh there's me
oh i gotta just walk away here we go
just walk away
boy this is the easy part
here's the weirdest thing how how does
everyone else know the right thing to do
except the people in charge i get it
there's no such thing as a clean
solution but the execution began with a
flawed premise it's the prison of two
ideas we stay forever or we get out
sounds a lot like marriage
but you could have redefined a mission
the way a football coach makes
adjustments at halftime or in this case
late in the fourth quarter you could
have left the place in the right order
american citizens first allies and
troops seriously how can we call the
taliban backward when everything we did
was backward you could have blown up all
the stuff so we didn't build them a new
army free of cost i believe that's on
page two and how to win a war for
dummies
so why is this so easy for a chuckle
bucket like me to come up with a chuckle
bucket's still drunk on cat's hand
sanitizer
because maybe it's just harder for joe
joe effed it up just like obama and
osama said he would like he's effed up
everything
remember when biden said the likelihood
there's going to be the taliban
overrunning everything and owning the
whole country is highly unlikely
joe biden probably doesn't remember
saying that so it's not the decision to
leave that's the problem it's that we
elected someone who couldn't preside
over the changing of his socks much less
the changing of a government fifth
graders could beat him in a game of risk
but we can't blame him he never hid his
incompetence the guy was the epitome of
the inside the beltway sponge soaking up
all the perks he was more for sale than
tvs before the super bowl though the
blame goes to the media who papered over
his bottomless incoherence who pretended
there was nothing weird about a
candidate who barely campaigned from his
basement who buried the hunter light bat
biden laptop story who portrayed trump
as the real unstable one this from deep
state geniuses who were right less often
than a college football player on his
sats
you know i'm not sure if i could even
blame the afghan president for scramming
lacking faith in biden versus knowing
what the taliban will do to you what's
your choice
obviously the biggest bonehead move of
all is thinking the government could
hold off the taliban for months
i mean why fight when the guy backing
you has less job security than an
incoming host of jeopardy
how did they miss that when it was as
obvious as the wig on brian kilmeade's
head
so it comes down to one word
accountability we need to account for
the corruption as well as the
incompetence we need to ask how they
came to this strategy was it based on a
memo rather than on men was it based on
consensus rather than reality whose
opinions mattered most and why who
scoffed at a rapid taliban takeover
maybe none of them scoffed at it and
they were lying to us all along so now
we've abandoned thousands of allies
something i couldn't see trump doing
oddly being america first often has
these secondary effects of helping those
who help us
that's right media the guy you called
hitler for four years had more
compassion than any of your dumb ideas
of the last decade
so instead we went from america first to
biden's america's worst
it's no build back better just more
accurate
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
she's the reason jim acosta goes to
therapy outnumbered co-host haley
mcinerney
she's such a strong anchor we use her to
dock my yacht on the weekend fox
business correspondent susan lee
he's so handsome other marines call him
semper fine
retired u.s marine corps bomb technician
and fox's contributor johnny joey joe
finally she's got the voice of an angel
if that angel smoked a package a for 30
years
buster's contributor
so i guess i should go to the veteran
first
uh cat no i'm only half oh that's right
so joey uh how did we get this so wrong
and how can we fix this
well actually i should ask you
you've been talking to a lot of people
currently in the military and outside
how do they feel about this
you know a lot of people i'm talking to
are working to get people out of
afghanistan
maybe president biden should i don't
know take notes give them a call i've
got some numbers yeah he could give them
a call some e5s and o2s you know lower
lower level officers and mid-level
enlisted are working around the clock to
get their interpreters or interpret
their families are those pronouns
what you just owe to a set of pronouns
my pronouns are he and hall so i'm not
really sure
are you going with this do not back me
in a corner last time i was on here yeah
i got backed in the corner on this stuff
i'm not a cultural reporter here okay
no listen
i'm beyond upset i i feel betrayed you
know i tweeted
the taliban broke my body but the united
states government broke my heart on this
right like you know we've sacrificed a
lot and that's okay my sacrifice was
justified the day it happened because
other people came other people came home
that day and lived but um but we've got
men and women serving right now and i
couldn't imagine being there either on
that flight line in kabul or sitting on
a base somewhere here knowing you could
be called up next and know that
this is who's going to have your back or
more importantly who isn't
and listen
on the excuses part this is the only
president really that did not inherit
this war yeah right because i mean even
with george w bush you could say it's
the incompetence of bill clinton they
could have squashed this thing to begin
with and and pretended to try
but joe biden was vice president
he helped preside over
the the
disaster that was iraq he opposed the
troop surge which was the second time we
ran the taliban out of the country just
for obama to claim victory for 2012 not
actually win the war right i know that
well i sacrificed a couple of legs for
that you're welcome obama you know what
i'm saying like hey i'll give that to
you bud but at the end of the day this
guy was vice president for eight years
of this war and you want to say you
inherited a situation like come on man
yeah oh you quoted him just there come
on man
so kaylee there are two things i want to
ask you one one is okay so
to joey's question about inheriting
something they always say well trump
started this trump started this but
there's something going on there that's
not being honest and i i just want to
ask you and i hate mind reading and
hypotheticals but could you
venture what might have been different
if trump were re-elected would he how
would he have done this differently i
know that's kind of hard to do uh no
it's not hard to do it's very easy i've
spoken to him i spoke to him yesterday
uh you would have never had an exit like
this he said to me yesterday we managed
to get afghanistan under control with
2500 troops it was a measured withdrawal
bit by bit to where we had it secure he
came close to wanting to pull out our
troops several times but he listened to
the generals he listened to those around
him and negotiated a conditions-based
withdrawal not only that the taliban
feared president trump they looked at
what happened to solemani they looked at
what happened when syria gassed its own
people he took action he's a man of
action and now you have a buffoon as our
commander in chief he vacations in
delaware he doesn't take questions he
turns his back on the american people
and president trump said it best he's a
surrenderer in chief we have surrendered
and the taliban is dictating united
states foreign policy to the most
powerful country on earth this is
pathetic and biden's directly
responsible the new taliban
[Applause]
now
i think kaylee was unfair to the taliban
uh susan uh you know they are yeah
that's tough
that's pretty tough well what about all
the weapons the billions of dollars was
it billions two trillion dollars oh yes
two thousand lives that were lost over
the last 20 years in afghanistan yeah
this were a corporation working at the
business angle
that's why he's very good he's very yes
i shift and transfer into that you would
uh they would just people would be fired
absolutely no one's resigning well this
stock would go to zero actually that was
the case because that is surrender it's
a it's a loss right but the nerd to nerd
i have to say the one good part of this
whole story
no i'm calling the afghani robotic team
nerds and i'm a nerd so i'm happy
they've made it to mexico yes but as you
know i really feel bad for the women in
afghanistan because these are women that
actually had a taste of freedom and a
taste of education for the last 20 years
and how do you tell your daughters that
have been promised a career and promise
education that that's not gonna happen
anymore how do you have a young daughter
right yeah no i mean joey's talked about
life under the taliban i can't imagine i
cannot simply imagine fearing for your
child's life your child's life not not
even their livelihood their life
the new taliban the new taliban how do
you feel about the new taliban
i think it's so interesting the way that
we're even having that discussion like
have they changed like i don't know
maybe they've changed maybe this is the
new taliban when like we don't give that
grace to like chris harrison from the
bachelor
right
he was fired forever
but we're like maybe the taliban's
changed like at this
[Laughter]
like at this you know if we're doing
things this way like the taliban has a
better chance of having a cookware line
at target than chrissy teigen
that's so true
that is so true yeah think about it yeah
they could actually host jeopardy you
don't want to give them pressure cookers
[Laughter]
only a bomb technician can make that
joke
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else